hey 42 here on Thursday the 24th of
February 2022 Russia invaded Ukraine
bringing conflict to Europe on a scale
that hadn't been seen since the Second
World War
at the time most if not all political
commentators believe victory for Russia
would be Swift and decisive with the
only real question being just how far
Putin would go before he was satisfied
the reasoning behind those bold
predictions was pretty simple in the Red
Corner was Russia one of the largest and
most feared military forces on the
planet led by seasoned campaigner and
notorious topless horseback rider
Vladimir Putin whilst in the blue and
yellow Corner was Ukraine outnumbered
and outgunned in every conceivable
department and led by a former comedian
Vladimir zelensky but as the weeks and
months dragged on it became abundantly
clear that victory for Russia was
nowhere near
and that got me thinking
if one of the world's most powerful
countries could be thwarted by a far
smaller foe today
what the [ __ ] happened in World War II
think about it in only a few months
between the end of 1939 and 1940 Nazi
Germany somehow conquered half of Europe
and a good chunk of North Africa growing
so powerful that it took the combined
efforts of Britain the Soviet Union the
USA and the whole host of other
countries to finally bring them down
when viewed alongside the war in Ukraine
that kind of freewheeling military
domination just doesn't make any sense
also consider that Hitler's assault on
world Freedom came just 20 years after
Germany suffered crushing defeat in
World War One and the whole situation is
downright baffling
so how did the Nazis snowball so
suddenly and why was the rest of Europe
so utterly powerless to stop Hitler's
war machine in his first few years I'm
glad you asked
if we go back to just after the first
world war Germany posed about as much
threat to World Peace as a damp flannel
under the Treaty of Versailles signed by
the newly installed Weimar government as
part of the German surrender Germany
reduced its military to 100 000
individuals and disbanded its Air Force
altogether
after some vigorous political arm
twisting and the odd persuasive nipple
[ __ ] thrown in for good measure
Germany also accepted full
responsibility for the war and agreed to
pay billions of dollars in reparations
to the rest of Europe
that was all very good in principle but
in practice Germany was practically
penniless and so the Weimar government
came up with a genius economic plan to
pay off its mounting debts it started
printing money by the truckload yeah you
don't need to have an economics degree
to see where this one's going all that
shiny new money flooded the German
economy triggering Mass hyperinflation
that at its worst saw 4.2 trillion
German marks being worth a single US
dollar
if you were unfortunate enough to be a
German citizen in the early 1920s
you didn't keep your money in a wallet
you needed a wheelbarrow like literally
people actually did that
by 1924 the German economy was on the
floor industrial output was at an
all-time low and widespread food
shortages left Millions on the point of
starvation
but just when the fields were fully
fallow help came from an unlikely fellow
the United States a country with which
Germany had been at War just six years
before
under what became known as the doors
plan Germany borrowed huge sums of money
from American Banks to fund a booming
cultural and economic recovery in the
mid to late 1920s
now running your country on farming
credit might sound a bit risky but the
Weimar government wasn't worried that
they were borrowing from America the
wealthiest most stable country in the
world what could possibly go wrong
as it happens that question had a free
Word answer
the Great Depression
that little cluster [ __ ] hit the US
markets in the summer of 1929 and
Germany suddenly found that those lovely
American Bankers who'd been giving them
so much money over the previous five
years were no longer picking up the
phone
so to sum it all up by 1930 Germany was
basically broke bereft of allies and
barely the Army to battle a beehive and
yet fewer than 10 years later they would
kick off World War II having somehow
transformed themselves into a world
superpower with the most feared Army in
all of Europe
when you say it like that such a
transformation sounds literally
impossible there simply wasn't enough
time and granted that's completely true
but it turns out the first seeds of
recovery had been planted more than a
decade before the Great Depression even
began
you see ever since the Treaty of
Versailles way back in 1919 Germany had
been secretly rebuilding its military
capabilities
under the Weimar government the German
police force was quietly given training
and Equipment of a distinctly military
nature
Harrow military groups were allowed to
grow unhindered into what soon became
small private armies and money was
discreetly funneled into the research of
forbidden military Technologies
same time state-sponsored clubs started
popping up all over the country publicly
they were perfectly innocent sports
teams youth programs Aviation clubs that
sort of thing but privately they were
little more than military training camps
in which potential leaders were being
picked and future luftwaffe Pilots were
primed
entire generation of Germans was being
readied for war behind closed doors
as per the Treaty of Versailles this was
all totally illegal so these efforts had
to be hidden from the International
Community and that did impose a kind of
natural limit on German rearmament but
the arrival of the Great Depression
dealt fiscal death to Divine our
Republic and it it's safe to say that
the bloke who took their place didn't
overly concern himself with the opinions
of Europe
you might have heard of him actually
he went by Adolf and when he
Consolidated power in Germany in 1933 he
was well and truly tired of the Treaty
of Versailles in fact he planned to tear
that document into neat little squares
so he could wipe his ass with it
during the mid to late 1930s Hitler
kicked off the biggest industrial
expansion in Germany's history as he
Tunes the economy in its entirety
towards a single end War
every man woman and child with a
functional body was put to work for the
greater good many were funneled into
factories producing Munitions and
vehicles of War some furrowed the fields
and others built massive public projects
including the now famous autobahns
Hitler paid for all of this with water
mounted to little more than financial
smoke and mirrors involving shell
companies and Shady promissory notes
known as mifo bills the whole thing was
entirely illegal and hopelessly
unsustainable but Hitler wasn't
interested in Germany's long-term
Financial stability
no
he was going to war and so long as he
won he'd be able to pay off Germany's
mounting debts with all of that loot in
other words he was turning Germany into
the biggest bully in the playground and
he was about to go after the rest of
Europe's lunch money by 1935 Germany's
army had tripled to 300 000 men and its
Air Force something that's very
existence with outlawed boasted 2 500
Cutting Edge warplanes now Hitler wasn't
exactly known for his modesty this is a
man who believed his people were part of
a master race that deserved to rule over
mankind and so he simply couldn't resist
showing off his shiny new Army to the
rest of the world at what he dubbed the
freedom to re-arm Rally
publicly admitting to Breaking the
treaty was a risky move what Hitler had
come up with a Nifty little excuse he
claimed he was re-arming as a purely
defensive measure and not by doing so he
wasn't threatening European peace but
actually helping to maintain it
that might sound ridiculous but what
happened next was downright insane
people actually believed him
looking back with the benefit of
hindsight it's hard to say exactly why
that was perhaps Europe's other
political leaders simply underestimated
just how dangerous Germany was becoming
under Hitler or maybe they were too wary
of rocking the boat for fear of plunging
the world back into war but no Hitler
put on a little [ __ ] military parade
to shout about his giant illegal Army
and the rest of the world simply rolled
over which only served to make the man
with the tiny mustache even bolder by
1939 on the cusp of the biggest war in
history all those years of fevered
preparation had borne lethal and
abundant fruit Hitler's Army contained
more than 4 million soldiers and his
power was absolute
but
alone doesn't entirely explain why
Germany was such a juggernaut in the
first two years of the war Hitler may
have commanded a stronger Army than any
of his enemies in a one-to-one
comparison but World War II wasn't a
singles match it wasn't even a tag team
it was a Royal Rumble involving more
than 50 countries and the combined
forces of the Allies far outnumbered
those of the Axis powers from day one
well actually day two when Hitler fired
the World War II starting pistol by
invading Poland it took Britain and
France two days to decide that might be
a problem and declare war so just 54
hours into a war that would last six
years the Nazis were vastly outnumbered
by the combined forces of the Allies
which also happened to have more money
more resources more ships and planes
more pastries more pretty much
everything and yet we've all read the
history books during the early part of
the war this apparent Underdog tore
through Europe like a Genetically
Enhanced pit bull
in just 19 months Hitler successfully
invaded Poland Denmark Norway Belgium
the Netherlands Luxembourg Franz
Yugoslavia and Greece with the Allies
powerless to stop him
as for how he did it well it turns out
Hitler had a trick up his well-starched
sleeve
[Music]
just 21 years separated the end of the
first world war and the start of the
second but during that time warfare had
changed forever
the trouble was only the Germans had
actually noticed
World War one was fought largely in the
trenches with long periods of stalemate
as huge forces dug in behind fixed lines
attacking such heavily defended
positions was certainly possible but it
cost the aggressor dearly however in
World War version 2.0 fortified trenches
received a huge Nerf thanks to advances
in tanks planes and other newfangled
Weaponry trenches had become defenseless
German tactics heavily hinged on these
hooking machines using their speed to
surprise enemies with a Turret of tanks
and motorized infantry the objective was
today is the enemy and decimates their
defenses this rapid shitstorm on the
ground was simultaneously supported in
the skies by newly designed dive bombers
that focused their efforts where enemy
resistance was strongest whilst also
harassing support lines
you probably know this approach to
murdering the enemy as the famous Nazi
Blitzkrieg tactics a word that literally
translates to lightning War but oddly
enough the term Blitzkrieg was never
actually used by the Germans the term
was picked up by Western media and
somehow stuck anyway in reality and
contrary to popular belief the
foundational principles of Blitzkrieg
strike fast and strike hard with
combined arms weren't anything new the
Germans simply combined classic military
ideas with modern technology in ways
that nobody had ever seen before
the final piece in this devastating
Blitzkrieg puzzle was to Humble radio
much like tanks radios were readily used
in the first world war but they were
large and unreliable and their pitiful
range made them about as viable as
shouting really loudly
but in World War II radios were much
smaller with much better range and so
you don't need to be Sun Tzu to know
that effective communication is an
incredible asset on the battlefield and
the Germans were quick to adopt the
radio as a means to coordinate their
devastating Blitzkrieg attacks of course
the Allies had access to all these tools
too they just hadn't had the time to
figure out how to use them as
effectively
at the start of the War the British
didn't have a single dedicated Armored
Division in their entire Army the polls
were still heavily reliant on Cavalry
and whilst the French actually had more
tanks than the Nazis they didn't arrange
them in Mass ranks like in the German
Panzer divisions but sprinkled them here
and there amongst the Infantry
most French tanks also lacked radios
meaning they simply had no way to match
the seamless coordination of Hitler's
ranks the tactics We Now call Blitzkrieg
was so effective that they allowed the
Nazis to defeat their enemies incredibly
quickly and often with minimal losses
France fell to the Nazi war machine in
six weeks Poland 35 days and Denmark in
just six hours sorry Denmark okay so
there's been a lot of background to
cover in this video but if I had to sum
it all up in a too long didn't watch it
would be something like this
the Nazis were so unbelievably
successful in the first two years of the
second world war because they were
better prepared than everyone else
that extra prep time allowed Hitler and
his generals to amass a huge
well-equipped Army gain a technological
Edge over their enemies and master the
nuances of mechanized Warfare before
anyone else you have to remember for
years Hitler knew he was preparing for
war whilst his neighbors were preparing
for peace
this crucial Head Start proved too
powerful for Europe to overcome and if
Hitler hadn't begun to believe his own
propaganda namely that his army was all
but Invincible the Allies might never
have caught up but as it transpired by
the middle of the war Hitler was no
longer a Schoolboy looking to steal some
lunch money
he more resembled a crazy homeless
person wandering the streets with piss
in his shoes trying to start fights with
absolutely everyone
in the summer of 1941 Hitler ordered the
invasion of the Soviet Union as part of
operation Barbarossa and six months
later he declared war on the United
States in the aftermath of the Japanese
attack on Pearl Harbor
strong though it was Nazi Germany didn't
have the Manpower nor the resources to
win a truly global war and yet that's
what Hitler ultimately got himself into
it took some time but eventually the
stronger larger economies of the Allies
started to out produce those of the Axis
powers Allied defeats became the
exception rather than the rule and
thanks to the bravery and sacrifice of
countless people from many different
countries one of the darkest periods in
human history was finally brought to a
close
thanks for watching